well going back to the topic of greed
how did
you know how the term yuppie was sort of
coined in the 80s
all the gentrification going on in new
york city probably around that time yeah
exactly
yuppies bmws all that yeah right a lot
of people being forced out of apartments
and things like that
did that growing up as a kid and seeing
some of that did that shape you at all i
know you were
more on well it's funny when i think of
the movie i just said now is all about
how polarized we are and how we
shouldn't be
and in a weird way it was the beginning
of us being a little bit polarized
it's funny because in my dorm i had like
weird art i found on the street and my
roommate uh
who went on to be um pretty stocked
republican
had um ronald reagan as a cowboy alf
a poster of money and a bottle of jack
daniels but
um but at the time
it was i'm gonna get into the
polarization
it was like you can have different
things you
lean towards but we could all talk and
and what's really hard for me right now
and
i do want to talk about because it's
super important to the movie i think i
might have made one of the most
important movies i've made
thus far is since 9 11 i've been seeing
the world just got really polarized not
just i travel like
a lot i thought first it was in our
country every country is super polarized
people are going far
right far left um and
it's getting very tribal and
it's losing everything that i think
that's important to me the most
important things are honesty
and integrity and i think in the
hope to fight for your side people are
willing to look the other way
at things that are wrong they're willing
to lie they're willing to
embellish the truth and i think when
that happens we're just gonna fall apart
as
as you know as a civilization and
i am super worried about that um
because i do think that it's irrational
uh we're allowing irrational behavior
where we're not um making people
accountable for when they do something
wrong
and you know if you talk about like
whatever in politics it's like
if you say well donald trump it's not
right that he did that and instead of
saying
yeah it's not right he shouldn't do that
they go but hillary did that
it's like it they're two separate
stories maybe what he did was wrong and
maybe what hillary did was wrong
the point is we need to focus on what's
right and wrong
um and so that has just gotten worse and
worse and
i love technology i think the internet
has the ability it had the it sort of
backfired on us
just in that people are losing empathy
for each other
because when we sit across from each
other and have an argument
and i say something and i see your
emotion and i see you're hurt
i will as a human being react to that
and be like wow that wasn't really right
what i said that was a little bit crazy
on the internet there's no face and
people
tend to just not listen to the other
side they just want to get out what they
want to say
and it just gets meaner and meaner and i
love technology and i wouldn't want to
take it away
i just think we need to evolve as humans
to be more empathetic without seeing
someone's face
and be more open to the fact that we may
be wrong sometimes and
ultimately just be to be more effective
like we need to listen to each other and
not get so polarized and
the 24-hour news cycle didn't help that
um
and it's gotten just worse because you
know
whichever way you lean it seemed like
fox started from my perspective
and then i i i watch a lot of the new
shows i've always watched and
it's so reactionary now that it's almost
escalating
and it's like i just kind of wish it was
just the news
um just facts and and and and
yeah it's been concocted this crazy
world and and and it's hard to go home
during um the holidays and and sit
around the table with
people that have opposite opinions we
literally in my home have brought up
like
no politics at the table i'm smart
sometimes we go into it and then it's
like we all
go all right we love each other let's
not talk about that so i
the movie i just made is called hot air
i was uh
had this idea for a while in my head and
um that
we need to fix this and um
a script got sent to my manager and she
sent it to me uh aleetri
and it was uh called hot air and my
producing partner amy keane read it and
she was like wow frank this is what
you've been talking about but it's a
beautiful little small story
uh and she knew i wanted to go back and
make an indie because my first movie was
an indian we can get into that a little
bit
um and i read this story and it was a
beautiful story about
just a small family drama it just
happened to be that
the lead was a right-wing talk show host
ala
you name you know rush limbaugh whoever
and his niece comes into his life that
he had never met from his estranged
sister who he hated
and um she's about to go into foster
care because
her mom's gonna go into rehab and she
sort of inserts herself
in his life and he wants to have nothing
to do with her and she's as clever as
him and says well
if you uh put me back into foster care
you're gonna i'm gonna tweet a message
saying
you're putting me back into the social
services that you rag on all the time
you know and then he realizes this niece
is really smart and the movie's about
the two of them going head to head and
you know it's not like at the end of the
movie he becomes a liberal and
you know but by the end of the movie he
becomes a better human
by listening to her and everyone in the
movie shifts just
a little bit and they're able to
communicate and and that
the goal of the movie was to make a
movie that you can see this movie with
your
republican or your liberal or your
conservative family and you can all go
together
and you can come home and be like all
right i'll listen to what you have to
say this time
so i it seems to have been getting that
kind of response it's coming out this
weekend so
i'm excited to see if it affects people
in the way that i
hope it does even if it's a few people
it'll be great did you used to watch a
lot of the 90s talk shows
remember like somebody would get up in
front of geraldo or jerry springer
and it was calm for a little bit and
then the first one
i threw the first rock and then it was
on i kind of was like one of those guys
that was
like anti that oh you were yeah yeah but
i i found them fascinating
and uh i just remember story because um
juliette lewis had done a movie with
adam and
she used to watch them all day and just
imitate people and then you realize how
she's so good at doing that just a
little offshoot
a little side shoot um yeah i wasn't a
big fan of those shows
i i they just kind of bugged me because
i felt like they were just
cashing in on people's um they're just
pushing buttons and
you know and it was like watching a
train crash you can't turn the other way
but i was able to turn the other way
so that wasn't my thing i loved
letterman oh yeah
i love things like that he was i like
that he was not always soft on everyone
that's true i always liked that he would
either like somebody and be cool with
them
and if he didn't like them he would he
wouldn't needle him a little yeah
yeah but he would do it with with a
little bit with class yeah and and
dignity and all those nice things yeah
right yeah i just was
curious if the sort of the evolution of
those
those talk shows has now turned into
people
in comments and and how i think it is
like
you know it all goes back to me to
integrity
it's because like you read a headline
and it's like the headline is just
to like exacerbate something or just
inflame
and and you realize they just want to
click and it's it's we're in this just
get do anything for attention
even at the expense you know it's like
sometimes the headlines just misleading
and then the misleading headline becomes
what everybody talks about and creates
rumors
and you know i mean it's like so i just
think people have to have integrity if
you just
that's the bottom line integrity
includes honesty
and you know uh treating people fairly
it's like
if everyone had integrity it would be
such a nicer world
and and we used to have more and we're
having less now
it was never perfect and we're always a
work in progress
um but i feel like this whole idea of
being a work in progress is is almost
thrown out the window i mean
i'm gonna just tangent into guns and
it's like we have all these problems
with people
wanting gun control and other people
saying well they're going to take guns
away
and and like look it's never going to be
perfect but we have a problem
and what always made america a great
country is we would work on fixing the
problem
you know i think i think it was like
trevor now we're talking about like we
had problems with cars so then you put
you know you make people wear seat belts
and you create rules and like and that's
what made this country great and
and i feel like now we're not willing to
even because people are taking such
sides we're not even willing to
work on fixing it even if it's baby
steps and and and
and that's you know i get i'm getting
into all these social issues because i'm
a filmmaker and
it's starting to become so important uh
to me that we start fixing some of these
things because i just feel like it
doesn't
feel like it's gonna be a great world in
20 30 40 years and
i don't have kids yet i want to have
kids and my friends have kids and i'm
just like i
want to do it for them
you